[Music]
did you guys hear about mike tyson
fighting a great white shark
what did the great white shark lose
i hope not on purpose knocked his ass
out did he [ __ ] up a white shirt okay so
like it has been announced that he will
be
fighting a great white on august 9th so
it hasn't happened yet
are they endangered didn't
is great white shark a nickname or the
animal what the
underwater what okay so i'm gonna lose
for sure
no way nah it's mike tyson i'm gonna
play the the ad
clip for shark week there's no winner oh
i get it
that's funny as [ __ ] that's fine that's
so funny
i love mike me too god damn he's jack
oh he looks good on the planet for 50.
he's back wait he's only 50. he's 55 of
them
mike's [ __ ] awesome you know he had
holyfield on his show
like like a year ago oh the podcast he
has a podcast called
hotbox and i [ __ ] love it we talked
about it here
i think it was that one hot boxing yeah
it's got to be we talked about one where
he was with the the one was crying man
wasn't that weird
he cries in every episode yeah [ __ ] you
guys don't even listen to hotbox
but i've heard him on several podcasts
and he always cry
cries in every episode on hot boxing
dude he's he's been through something
is he blazing while he's on the hot box
yeah and he he
and by the way whoever's on his show
he's like it is such a pleasure to have
this person
and every single time he's all about
love he could have jared the [ __ ]
rapist subway guy on and he was like
it's such a pleasure man like it's
like it really is he's all loved he's so
sweet wow
i loved his cartoon i had a friend that
always cried when he smoked weed and i
didn't want to smoke weed with him
anymore
because it becomes tiring sometimes you
just want to like
start out yeah and laugh at the space or
something
with him mike tyson well it's hard
because every time mike
invites me i'll have to say yes and you
and the tiger are just like and he's
like
you know he's so hard cause i want to
kill people and i'm all like
you got any more chips dude his joe
rogan
talk about work not working out because
he's too afraid of unlocking the inner
demon or whatever
the god of war i was like this is the
scariest [ __ ] i've ever heard of it
yeah you can't even jump rope do nothing
because then he'll like see someone else
go and he's like i gotta [ __ ] beat
that
[ __ ] soul so good man
i know like he makes michael jordan look
like a [ __ ] piece of nothing
yeah like a lazy phone yeah i love the
part where he was uh i think joe rogan
asked him he's like
hey uh do you want your your your kids
to box he goes
oh my son he goes to private school and
that's all he's a little bit
yeah pretty much my son's a little
[ __ ] [ __ ] he can't be boxing and
that's good hate to be mike tyson's son
yeah people always challenging you what
if he's like a really nice
dad oh you mean like oh living up to it
yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's the biggest shout out like i
think of eminem's daughter
i'm like oh dating bailey as her like
being her she have a boyfriend
but it would be so hard to date cause
like
he's pretty crazy but what if he's
really cool he could be
yeah well okay so mike tyson for those
of you that don't know
he has a 50 to 6 career score
with 44 out of the 50 victories being
knockouts yeah
and that's not including animals i
thought many animals
i would say that i don't know any other
fighter or boxer
that just gave that level of excitement
and just energy and like dude mayweather
was the most boring champ i've ever seen
i'm sorry i've watched many
many fights very technical i understand
he's my record a winner
and he's great but it's there's no
entertainment
i don't understand the sport enough to
know what he's doing like i get that
he's chess mastering i get it i just
don't visually understand the sport i
think that's what was so great about
mike is you don't have to know boxing
like i was he's a brawler just watching
him as a child and and i don't know [ __ ]
and i'm all like
this is so tight and then i play mike
tyson punch out
and and then and then that was just like
a lot of kids you know yeah mayweather
it's like i could put my feet up it's
gonna take a while
mike tyson's like don't blink because
anything could happen
any second and they're like don't
[ __ ] blink at all and then he bites a
zero mike tyson
is legit like any kid who grew up in the
90s
mike tyson's i guess he's 50 and five
but he's like [ __ ] hundred
to zero against most of us because i
couldn't beat him in [ __ ] mike
tyson's punch ever
[ __ ] lost every time so i got a game
genie
i did yours i reckon i didn't even make
it to that level man i get to that soda
pop guy and he [ __ ] me up
soda pop guy [ __ ] me up too but i got
when i got to tyson he would wreck me
every time
seriously so this whole this new
announcement about him fighting a great
white
he said quote i equate this with
overcoming my fear of getting back into
the ring at 54 years old i learned from
his experience during short week that
whatever intimidates me i'm still
able to step up to the challenge of
overcoming anything that would prevent
me from accomplishing my life's mission
of reaching my highest potential in life
and bringing me closer to god
isn't he coming back to also do an
exhibition back uh exhibition match
with roy jones jr that's the that's the
newest news
that i've recently heard about really
gonna fight a great white but
i don't think they'll let they'll let
they're [ __ ] around i mean i know
peta will
never allow that tree yeah for sure he
would probably stick
it they're calling it tyson versus jaws
rumble
on the reef they'll probably put him in
a shark cage
have him stare at it until the shark
turns around and swims away
they said that tyson will face off
against the animal in the name of
research
yeah see he'll see what they said with
famed
ring announcer michael buffer calling
the shots these two heavyweights will
square
let's get rid of the rumble guy yeah
where mike tyson will try to score a tko
over the massive shark
all in the name of research i hope it's
just a what's the tko though
i mean but with the top what would he
get knocked out of the ring punch him
under water
i don't know he gets knocked out of the
ocean onto the move so slow he's gonna
be like
it'll probably be a producer in a rubber
suit does this sound
familiar to anyone because i really feel
like i have reported
previously on jk news of some celebrity
fighting some animal for shark
shark week really like celebrity not
mike tyson or like a bear
or i remember maybe a crocodile or an
alligator i remember reporting some
celebrities
fighting an animal hmm i don't know
maybe you guys can run it might have
been ted nugent
oh yeah he's known for the [ __ ] beer
he loves hunting
but yeah like bart mentioned uh mike
tyson will be returning to boxing
to fight 51 year old former champion
roy jones jr i'm kind of scared for that
ones i'm a big fan of both of them you
think mike's going to lose
not more than typing whoa so i'm a big
fan of both of them not more than
michael
any of your dogs roy no no not more than
tyson for sure but the problem is roy
jones he's been
sharp this whole time and he hasn't had
all those internal demons he had to work
on
so like for knowing mike because he's my
homie of course
so knowing mike because he's been
working on those internal demons
yeah and he he's [ __ ] ripped now he's
finally getting back in the ring
i want him to have a confidence booster
you know like i wanted to come in and
beat the [ __ ] out of someone
or maybe even face holyfield because
that's like the old nemesis
rather than come in and face someone
even though it's exhibition
face someone that's had their [ __ ] put
together the whole time
you know does anyone even remember who
won the tyson holyfield fight
uh didn't holyfield get his ear bit off
well yeah right but nobody remembers the
result but that's the reason that's
considered a dq or what exactly no i
thought no he was losing yeah i think
that's the reason why
holyfield won because i think he out of
desperation that's why he started doing
all this foul [ __ ] wow yeah
i thought it was because he kept getting
head butters it was that's his
explanation yeah oh well in my head
mike tyson won because i'm like that guy
got his ear bit off yeah
and everyone that's all anyone talked
about yeah you know what i did
uh recently is uh violence detox
you did a violence detail yeah because i
think that
um so i know that any you know like a
confirmation bias right so any
if you if you decide to
focus on something in life and magnify
it and then that becomes your life that
becomes reality right so i was like
i didn't realize that i have so much ph
ptsd from the past that
i i'm almost addicted to violence like
it's just there like it's normalized to
the point where
oh like i might be training in a violent
manner like i'm doing fighting right or
like
i am um watching violent films or
videos or i sometimes find funny
things in violence like you know like
home birth
like weddings rumbles yeah you saw that
[ __ ]
like i went to see it after you said
that there's like [ __ ]
chairs flying homeless people fighting
like it's funny but it shouldn't be
funny right
but i think that it's been so normalized
in my brain that you desensitize
yourself right so then
i was like okay let me see what life is
like if i don't stir up that
part of myself uh let me just see how
much i can stay away from it and i was
like
oh [ __ ] i actually watched a lot like
whether it was my phone
um i scroll it through instagram there's
like even
even like like right now there's a whole
thing with people getting attacked
because of racism or whatever
and so every time i see it i didn't
engage in it i just passed like i just
kind of like
buried my mind to where it's only
looking at tree houses and people
sailing and
then like relaxing things and people
having fun right
and then i was like oh [ __ ] this is uh
changing the way that i feel on a daily
basis yeah you become what you consume
yeah and i was like damn my mom was
right those violent video games
was kind of [ __ ] with me and i don't
like to admit that [ __ ] dude whenever i
played grand theft auto for an extended
period of time and then tried to go
driving
yeah i just wanted to run every red
light like i'd
like in my head i'm like this is okay
this is why [ __ ] boomers shouldn't
play grandpa
i was in high school but then being
conscious of it i think was much more
was way better than just kind of like
having it being a part of your life
because i always had scenarios where if
i
um if my mind drifts right i'm driving
and i'm like
what if this person just got out of the
car and started shooting at me oh i'd
probably kill them
you know and then like you you create
scenarios in your head right
but it's just brainstorming sessions the
same way i would brainstorm a business
idea
oh you know what this burger's great you
know what to be even greater
is we put three slices of cheese or like
and then but the same type of
mentality i would have for like what if
i'm walking down the street and this guy
goes give me your money well i'll kick
him in the nuts and then i'll do this
and then there's no your spin-out
thoughts were more violent
yes yeah and that was so normal in my
mind
that i didn't realize that maybe it had
an effect
on also how i am feeling or projecting
emotions or whatever right
because i would treat it the same way
like it's the same thing
as like oh a hamburger or like whatever
when it shouldn't be
so then when i caught that i was like
okay let me see how much
how differently i would feel if i stayed
away from these feelings
is there something you're doing instead
no i mean he's just watching like
yeah yeah like i'm being he's made his
feet all positive like
right right right so like i'm watching
people go sailing
uh i'm watching how do you feel
differently it's definitely more
relaxing
and i start to think that the world is a
good place because
you keep thinking and seeing good things
right then i was like thinking about how
uh there's a lot of struggles online
right now and
for me it's not like about um burying it
but managing
the dose of what you see you need to
balance it like you need to see that
there's also bad but there's also good
right
but it's easy to feel helpless and yeah
for sure and sad and stuff
yeah yeah but in the past i would just
be like i could consume any content but
i
have a strong personality doesn't affect
me but i'm like no you're human
subconsciously it does subconsciously
affect you
so now i'm more conscious of the uh
content that i consume
and spend time doing that's good it's
like an addiction it's crazy
i do think we're addicted to negativity
big time
because it feels good
[Music]
you